hey guys anna welcome back to leia
inspired podcast super excited to have
all of you so this podcast is powered by
icon plus so i'm going to give you guys
a really quick icon news announcement so
exciting news from the icon foundation
south korea's largest job portal sarah
man hr and icon loops will utilize the
icons public blockchain to tackle and
detect forgery and fraud in the
recruitment industry so some exciting
news there so today i have a really cool
guy on the show if you don't know it's
somebody that's grown his twitter
account just in 2020 in the last five
months from zero to almost 30k so it is
fitness coach dan go hey how are you
doing what is going on nice to see you
and all of the people who are watching
this
yeah we've got quite a few viewers right
now yeah it's great to have you so this
is really cool actually because you grew
your twitter account um in literally
just five months so what the hell how
did you do that how did you go from
because i found you at 5k um you're
nearly at 30. you're definitely going to
overtake me i know it so like huge
congrats
and how are you doing it
uh
it is a lot of it's like a full-time job
let's just say that and
um when i got into twitter in the first
place i think it was april is right
before my
daughter was gonna get bored literally
actually did
the accounts got born
when i was in the delivery room
yeah so we just put an epidural in my
wife because she was feeling like super
pain and then
and then once it started to do its thing
she started to calm down i was tweeting
like crazy
and uh how did you feel about you
tweeting while she's going through
neighbor well the funny thing is is that
one coveted hit oh
it actually was very scary right because
i got all my clients from say like
facebook and all this kind of stuff and
if you don't know i help entrepreneurs
with their fitness and all this kind of
stuff and
when that happened it was a very scary
kind of like situation obviously
everyone's kind of like not signing up i
had a couple clients cancel on me and i
was just like what the heck am i gonna
do now and
twitter was just one of those things
that was just lying there in which i had
always seen it as a platform in which i
wanted to spread my ideas but never
really took it seriously and then once
my baby was about to come out and covet
hit i was like
it let's just start tweeting on
twitter and uh one of the first people i
talked to was ed latimore and uh yeah he
was mentoring me the whole time and
actually zooby zubi was one of the other
guys who kind of like helped me push me
in the past that i'm on right now
so what is like the main thing that
you've learned about growing an audience
because a lot of people want to grow an
audience whether they want to admit it
or not and people want to grow an
audience and i keep hearing there's a
lot of money twitter so you know how
there's like money types
of politics twitter so money twitter i
saw a guy sort of say if you want to
grow your audience you have to speak in
absolutes um is that just or is
that actually something here
there is something to that because the
way that i tweet is somewhat ambiguous
and i will go into absolutes and
i think one of the things i tweeted
today was loneliness is just a sign that
you're not friends with yourself
and when i say something like that and
when i say something in such an absolute
way it brings so
many different variations of people's
reactions
so i leave my tweets like very ambiguous
because even if i was very detailed in
what i was gonna say people are just
gonna take it and see it in their own
perception
so i'm just like well it i'm just
gonna say exactly what is on my mind and
i tweet from the hip like crazy like a
lot of the tweets that i come up with or
whatever it's just like something that
pops up in my mind i'm just like shoot
it off
and when i do that i don't care about
the response
i just i know people are going to
respond either negatively or positively
but they're going to respond with their
own mirror essentially yeah
yeah so
it's true i hear you i think like people
often sort of um you know you can
explain something so simply like i've
seen it and you like it doesn't even
need that much explanation you just sort
of say it and it's still taken the wrong
way so i think there's something
powerful and sort of leaving it quite
ambiguous i guess
absolutely i believe that you everyone
should leave their tweets ambiguous i
believe no one should leave any details
towards them because
again people are just going to take it
with their own eyes and you know one
person can feel the elephant and be like
oh it's like it's whatever it is the
other person can feel the trunk and
think it's like a completely different
animal
so
i'm i'm just like
humans are perception machines
so why not just give them what they want
i have a question then um it's quite
actually interesting for me to ask you
um i'll tell you after why i asked this
question but do you ever get like any
hate on twitter or do you get it me you
do i've never seen it what did you get
well what's going on with you uh okay so
you get like the low level stuff like
people just saying well i'm so
disappointed you said that therefore i'm
following you and then
it's the announcement that they're
unfolding now
it's like what thank you for tweeting
this so i don't have to you know
and you want to respond like the the
visceral side of me wants to respond
back right yeah the human nature side of
me so i've also had hate where people
literally
message me and they're like up
right really and i'm just like i i
didn't even do that you know and but
honestly girls get it much worse than
guys do like they they just i've seen
the messages i've seen the messages it's
it's hard so yeah
i get that i get my hate but you know
i think i think twitter profiles like
yourself you probably get a little bit
more creepy creepy stuff going but
for me i get i get a good amount of pay
but it's usually about one percent of
the stuff that i tweeted out or one
percent of the people that interact with
my tweets so 99
99 out of 100 i'm getting everyone
that's just like either contributing to
the conversation or
uh or agreeing with me or
disagreeing in a very cool way right
okay and then for the people that just
hate um
i personally feel that they are living
in a
in a reality in which it is hell for
them already
for them to spit vitriol to you
for them to hate on you right so
i just block i ignore and the human
nature part of me actually wants to
respond back to these you
know like i do i do like it's all in us
like we want to react we want revenge
but then the greater side has to say
that you know guess what this is going
to happen this is the game you're
playing so suck it up buttercup ignore
block move on
yeah you know i i totally agree with you
and i think that's a really good
mentality particularly because you've
only been on the platform since i think
you said april um so when i um we were
sort of chatting earlier just so
everyone knows
earlier i didn't actually answer your
questions we had some technical issues
and you asked me when did i first get on
twitter
and i've been on twitter i think since
like 2000 and i don't know gosh maybe
it's fast i don't know years but i've
never like made an effort to grow it
until the whole corona thing happened
because i was like what the hell
something else to do let's grow twitter
um and when i did i got a lot of hate
um
so it's just really interesting and i
think only more now
um you know i've interacted with quite a
lot of different people and they've
given me you know a lot of different
advice which is literally just you know
don't worry about it just totally block
and ignore essentially yeah yeah
essentially like you don't want to let
them get to you and kind of ruin your
shine and that's what a lot of people do
when they hate they just want to make
your days horrible so
the best the best revenge is just being
really happy and just going about your
day and still doing the work
you know
yeah absolutely i like to say that
twitter is the ultimate test for
yourself right
it's like how confident are you in
yourself how much do you care about
other people's opinions how much do you
actually care
and then you will find that you'll get
all these fields like someone says
something like really you know
messed up to you or says something
offensive
or some says something that you feel
offensive then i look at that when i get
offended i'm like oh why did i get
offended by that
is it because of what they said or is it
because of something that's actually
happening inside of me that gets
offended that wants to be angry about
this kind of stuff so i think it does
like a practice a little bit
yeah i think i think you're actually
totally right and i think you often find
that when somebody has um an issue with
you it's often just sort of like a
projection of their own sort of inner
self conflict but i will just mention i
have actually just switched my cameras
so look at the quality it's just dropped
i've had to switch my cameras can you
feel like
i feel like your skin got darker so i
feel the quality like you know it's like
you got more tan so the quality just
increased right
i know i'm here pale right now so any
time someone's going to get starcraft
i'm just i'm just like yeah well
did get darker i don't know what
happened but anyway i want to talk to
you about bitcoin right um because i'm a
bitcoiner
and the reason if anyone's confused why
i brought a fitness guy on to a
crypto-ish podcast is for one huge
reason and the huge reason is literally
that i think there's a synergy between
um crypto and well between bitcoin and
between health and fitness and i think
the synergy is that when you're in
bitcoin you often refer to yourself as
being red pill right so taking personal
responsibility over your finances now
there's health and fitness twitter and
whatever and i find you guys are taking
personal responsibility over your health
um there's synergies there and we've
been following each other for a few
months so i want to get your opinion
right firstly do you own any bitcoin are
you even in bitcoin like just simply to
start
you know when bitcoin actually was about
maybe two years ago when it was just
like shooting to the stars right
coinbase was up and i was buying as much
bitcoin as i could on coinbase and then
i was into the altcoins i was into the
altcoins like huge
and uh yes i do have bitcoin uh but it's
not a large part of my portfolio it's a
part of where i feel like if it hits
then awesome if it doesn't hit then i'm
not going to be affected by it
whatsoever
um
yeah but i still have these all coins i
don't even know which all coins do you
have oh great she has
i'm probably gonna like okay
i'll look at my block folio right now
wait who are you in there okay who did
you say
i'm just using it
yeah i'm probably looking like the
biggest crypto new but it all right
so it's okay wait firstly firstly i just
want to say everyone showdown go love
okay like go follow him on twitter he's
brilliant he's really cool and like he's
interested in bitcoin so we need to just
really appreciate that he doesn't know
huge amounts but that's cool he doesn't
need to it's all about spreading the
word so no pressure just tell us
okay so
uh the majority is in bitcoin um i would
say half of what i have in the majority
is in ethereum
and then the rest yeah the rest are
split between all coins which are like
monero
0x
um
i forgot do you hold any link do you
hold any legs did you see like we were
all talking about
you know what that's what made me kind
of like under exuberant because everyone
was tweeting about link and i heard
about link from my friends cottage i was
in my friend's cottage and we were just
watching this um this documentary and my
friend's like hey man have you ever
heard of link
and then because i was part of the whole
altcoin situation back then
you know where everything was just like
exuberant after i heard that i was like
i'm sorry bro i'm sorry i'm just
checking out right now i can't listen to
this at this moment i have no
know what i don't want to put any more
money into bitcoin so i have walton
chain i have um yeah omg i have
okay don't worry
yeah
just sit on it and wait till the whole
thing sort of explodes just sit right
now i have a i mean like the position is
good enough that i feel if it if it does
hit then i will you know it's going to
be a pretty big takeaway but yeah if it
doesn't hit
i'm
not going to be searching for a second
mortgage or anything like that
um what's the story okay so i first
heard about bitcoin when my friend was
buying off the dark web
uh so so
on silk road silk road when silk road
was still out
and he would buy marijuana and all this
kind of stuff before marijuana was legal
i'm in canada so marijuana is legal here
is there throughout the entire country
throughout the entire country but then
um but then the weed's not that really
it's not that good because you have to
smoke the government stuff but anyways
right that's okay
yeah so so
i heard about from my friend and my
friend told me to put money into it and
i'm just like well that you know
this is a time when bitcoin was like a
hundred bucks a bitcoin or something
like that i'm like it's too risky man
this is like years ago and then
and then uh when everyone was getting
exuberant about two to three years ago
that's when i got really into it that's
when i got into like the bitcoin reddit
the cryptocurrency read it i started to
just do research on all these coins i
what i thought was research right yeah
getting sound pretty right yeah kinda so
after i i invested a pretty big amount
into yeah
cryptocurrency back then and then
um
and then ever since then i've just been
you know we've seen bitcoin go up to
like 20k
went down to like whatever was 6k at a
time and after that point i was just
like you know what i'm just going to let
this ride i'm not going to put more
money into it and just see exactly what
happens with all this because usually
when you read about the stories the
stories are oh i forgot i had this hard
drive like 10 years ago yeah and i
checked my hard drive and i had like
five bitcoins in there so
those are like the stories that kind of
inspire me a little bit so i'm just like
i'm not going to touch it i'm not going
to play around with that i'm not going
to like
uh you know what they day trade with it
or whatever it is
i'm just going to i'm just going to hold
it and let it do its thing
yeah i don't you got weights to lift you
know fitness to get and all that stuff
which we're gonna get into so i want to
talk about all of that um but i was
gonna ask you though because i tweet a
lot about crypto and we have like often
like back and forth kind of like banter
or whatever so i wanted to know what is
your opinion on crypto twitter like does
it because every every of course there
are so many different niches right so
like i'm saying you've got politics
you've got feminist twitter you've got
all the all these different things so
every every sort of niche claims to be
like the most dominant the most powerful
the most annoying but i really do think
um as much as i love this community it
could be
the most toxic community on on twitter i
could be wrong i could be wrong don't
don't bite me um i could be really wrong
but like i just want to know your
opinion like i don't know you're a money
twister and fitness twister so i just
left which is that kind of well let's
just say you're biased to a certain
degree you know like a little bit
i i don't have a lot of uh experience
interacting with crypto twitter so the
only things that come to me are the
stuff that you post or when crypto
twitter guys are getting into fights
right
that's not good so it's crypto twitter
it reminds me a lot of science twitter
right okay and when i say by science
twitter i'm speaking specifically from
the fitness angle of things
not from any other type of science so
we have a lot of intellectuals who are
incredibly smart some of the smartest
people in the world
yeah like bar none i'm talking for the
cryptocurrency space and the fitness
science space
these but they have
it's hard for them to control emotions
and to take people that disagree with
them to a certain degree right
so yes i know what you're getting at so
they're gonna like throw like i have
seen playground insults thrown
from some of the smartest people i've
ever seen on the planet
and it's only because they they
basically had this like you know beef or
whatever with some other crypto guy or
some other science guy so
my only experience was like crypto has
been the positive stuff that you've been
posting and then in the in the odd time
when drama happens you know i see that
too
yeah yeah okay interesting i mean
somebody has just commented now i'm
going to throw it up on the screen
somebody says here today is passionate
it's the best and the worst no you're
fine no one's in trouble okay it's true
it is passionate um it is the best and
is the worst um
yeah i mean i i get what you're getting
out of the whole science thing um
um it's it's i don't i think it's a fact
of people just being ex just really
exuberant about it you know
and then you have people who are really
exuberant about science and also like
the different types of science and the
different types of evidence and then
when one evidence doesn't match up to
the other that's when dissonance happens
and then they get into these arguments
and they're like no my way is the best
and no my
my crypto is the best you know and oh
yeah well all the cryptos are the best
yeah oh don't say that you'll get in
trouble okay okay
no i'm joking it's fine um so i kind of
want to move on a little bit um because
like i said you are a fitness coach um
you're very motivational you know it's
always like go chase your dreams every
day get up go like
you know it's closer
so i'm similar as well and so i think
that's kind of like where the synergy is
so i kind of want to get your opinion
like
firstly how are you constantly staying
so active so motivated um you know it's
been difficult with everything that's
going on with the whole corona virus
like you're hitting the gym like what is
up how are you just like foot on the gas
all the time
i i look i don't i don't feel like like
i am foot on the gas all the time i i
really
actually do feel like i am a guy who
really honors his rest and work periods
a lot
so how am i able to kind of like say be
stay productive and yeah kind of like
stay high energy well
i have a thing which is like standards
over schedule so my standards for me are
to hit the gym four times a week to do
heavy lifting not for my body that's for
my body but it's more for my brain and
my sanity i've gone from understanding
that the workouts themselves they're
great from a physical standpoint but
they make you the smartest person that
you can ever be
and they have the research to back this
so so for me i have a ton of reasons why
i need to work out and keep myself
active
and the reason i kind of like just am
staying on this path and even when i got
let's just say like five thousand
followers if i've made you know whatever
seven figures or do or do anything my
whole thing has been mission based it
has been to help as many people as
humanly possible and i have a specific
number which i'm not going to which i'm
not going to announce but i have a
specific number in my mind of which of
how many people's lives that
i want to change
so for me every time i wake up and every
time i post on twitter
i am always just relying relaying myself
back to that mission
and i feel like i am more purpose driven
and mission focused than i am monetary
focused but both go you know one in the
same essentially
so
i would say like that's why i keep the
gas pedal on and also because i've been
through a lot of tragedy i've
been through so much tragedy in my life
that uh it's made me appreciate the very
simple things in life so i've lost uh
i've lost my mom when i was like very
young
and i lost a brother he was murdered and
i don't want to get you know too deep
into these things but i'm gonna say that
a lot of times when you go through these
types of situations in your life all the
rest of the that happens is like it
fails in comparison to what the actual
let's just say what my actual purpose in
life is which is too which is to love
other human beings and to make their
lives as as best as i can within my own
power essentially
yeah i totally hear you um that's cool
that you shared that with us i think
that um i can totally understand you
know it really does put everything into
perspective and i think um you know i'm
obvious i i'm obviously younger than you
but i think at the same time i've still
been able to sort of see
um particularly amongst you know my
friends growing up and things like that
you often find that those whose lives
are just like so perfectly easy um they
sort of aren't able to get any
perspective
um
it's incredibly interesting like i'll
just give you a really ridiculous
example but like i think um a girl i i
used to know i remember she came out of
like a long-term relationship and it was
like the hardest thing in the world for
her and i'm just like damn like how how
is that the hardest thing in the world
you know um you know you weren't married
you know there was no engagement um like
how was it just because the life has
been so perfect so that it's very
difficult then to sort of tackle
whatever comes next
yeah that's i so i have a daughter now
and then
i almost have to force myself to watch
her struggle
right oh wow yeah and and the thing is
is that i need she needs to struggle
because that's the only way she's gonna
learn on her own and kind of be
self-sufficient
and she's just like four months right
now so i'm being i'm being a big dad but
anyways yeah
so that's pretty sweet
yeah so you can't you can't really grow
if you don't have these hard things
happening or if you don't actually
force yourself to do hard things so this
is the reason why i feel like
everyone's trying to toughen themselves
up with like physical activity they're
like i gotta do a tough mudder so i can
prove that i'm like the toughest version
of myself and we have to do these like
outside
outside discomfortable things in order
to prove things to ourselves
and
we have to do those things because you
have to put yourself through really
tough to understand that you're
going to get through the other side
probably stronger
and if you haven't been through really
tough or people have
not wanted to expose you to these things
when they actually happen you won't know
how to deal with yourself you won't know
how to use how to turn tragedy into
triumph you won't know how to turn grief
into meaning like these are these are
kind of like the building blocks of how
we're able to get better as human beings
or hopefully get better as human beings
so yeah tragedy is a huge part of my
life
and
only because i found a very positive
meaning from it
yeah i totally agree with you i think
like
you know it's i think some of the
greater i think some of
genius comes from tragedy in my honest
opinion um like so i have i'm a huge fan
of charlie chaplin i'll just sort of put
that out there it's like totally random
um
and
personally for me like he's not just a
comedian like his his work is just art
um and it and like
the the idea with him is that like he
had a very his life was very difficult
he came from extreme poverty um so it's
kind of like tragedy and genius are like
never quite sort of far apart in my
opinion
um but
i do sort of want to like talk a little
bit more about your fitness sure um
and a lot of the stuff that you tweet um
you tweet a lot of stuff about like
gender roles
um you know sort of male responsibility
so there's a lot of like encouragement
for sort of like men to be more madly if
you sort of want to put it like that
right
you know people talk about like
testosterone being on a global all-time
low
um
what is going on
the
it is the comfort of society that is uh
basically driving everyone down at this
very moment uh the more comfortable that
we can make everyone the more that
they're they're gonna complain
and the more that they're gonna rely on
other people to do things for them and
one of the most self-sufficient things
that you can do is get yourself into
shape it is personal power in a bottle
and quite frankly if your life is
comfortable and you're sitting on
watching netflix and you're getting paid
to do it and you have a very comfortable
job and you have a very comfortable life
what is it to say that's on you to go
and hit the gym and to start eating
healthy when everyone else
is not
right so you're saying because it's
become like socially acceptable to do
nothing to just sit and watch traffic is
that what you're saying i i think
honestly the reason why people hire me
is because
weight loss is a very uphold struggle in
the day that we live in right now
because
number one you walk outside into the
city you're not gonna see anything about
food advertisements you're not gonna see
anything but like mcdonald's go drink
this go eat that whatever it is
you are inundated with so much influence
to eat
that it's going to be hard for you to
say okay well i don't really want to hit
mcdonald's today you know like literally
it's been subconsciously programmed into
you to eat these foods so that's like
the first thing the second thing is you
have to deal with everyone else's food
habits around you that just makes it
hard you know so
what what i like to do with my
particular clients is literally get them
back to homeospaces
you know which is
which is not a six-pack for them it's
not about like being a six-pack and
looking like arnold or looking like
brad pitt from fight club
literally it's just about being able to
take off their shirt at the beach and
not feel fat
right i i want to get them down and
literally i say this to them all the
time i'm just like i'm just trying to
create a body that's preventable from
avoidance diseases
and
and if we are able to do that then guess
what you're going to look a lot better
too and you're going to feel a lot
better
and um and personally for me i again i
look at it as an uphill struggle for a
lot of people obviously
the numbers are not lying to us at this
very moment
so it is very hard for people to get in
shape and the the government and society
is not making it any easier at all it's
actually making it harder
it's really interesting and you know
sometimes
food has a huge part to play in it and
you keep
delicious looking mangoes um and you
showed us how to cut it i watched it it
was like you've got to cut it like this
that's super cool i'm gonna try that but
that's really interesting so i want to
get your thoughts like what would be a
good sort of
really sort of light kind of diet
something to do because i've been doing
something really bad all of my life okay
i'll hands down admit that now i have a
i have like it's i wouldn't call it an
addiction but i have like a love of
cereal
and um that i think is just gonna stay
with me until i'm a grammar like and
i've tried recently to to change my
breakfast but i can't i'm not i'm not
having like super sugary cereal it's
just like even like like brown flakes or
something i just love the milk and the
cereal i love it every morning but
that's not a great breakfast that's what
i've been that's what i've had well it
depends right the way i look at
breakfast is
depends upon energy needs so if you are
walking around and you're walking about
the city you're doing ten thousand
fifteen thousand steps and you're just
like super active and that'd be like
yeah you should be eating like a you
know breakfast cereal or whatever it is
and you said something very interesting
too which was like i feel like something
like i feel bad or eating cereal is bad
or whatever
i personally feel with every single
person that they should get rid of the
good or bad mentality it's like i ate a
cake they're whoa i'm bad i ate a cake
you know
i love the garlic i love it yeah thank
you
but what people do is they are vilifying
food that they see on an everyday basis
and you love to eat cereal right so
why not figure out a way to eat a diet
that has cereal as a part of it right
and you talked about my mangoes before
so
i remember my friend marshall he posted
this thing about fruit he's like you
know uh something like unpopular opinion
fruit doesn't make you fat and all these
fruits all these fruit people were just
like no you're a idiot like all
this kind of stuff
and and the thing is like you don't want
to make any food bad if you like it then
you should incorporate it within reason
and within responsibility so the first
thing that i would love to do is just
like to look at food as cost
rather than look at food as like a good
or bad type of thing it's almost like
i'm going to go to um
what's like a it's like they have a cvs
or something like that or a drugstore
it's like a drugstore it's like a you go
there and you can buy like your hair
gels
let's just say this you know like we're
you go to the chemist or
i think i'm doing it the wrong way right
here let's just say you're going to best
buy do you have a best buy or whatever
we don't have the best buy we didn't do
that come on so you're you're walking in
some department store you're looking at
clothing
right
and then and then this is how i look at
food i look at food from a cost
perspective rather than looking at food
from a good or bad perspective so if
you're gonna buy a leather jacket so to
speak you would measure out okay well
how much do i have in my bank account uh
how much am i willing to spend on a
leather jacket uh do these things
correlate with the leather jacket that
i'm seeing in front of me
i would like to break it down to a math
level of whether or not
you should be taking that in at that
point and if i i i asked this qua ask
this question to my clients all the time
so i'm like okay how much is a
uh
performance model three tesla they'll be
like boom it's like 70k or whatever it
is right
so i'm like okay cool how much does a
100 gram banana cost your body
yeah
and then they're like
what do you mean
right
like i'm just saying like what's the
cost and they would say i don't know
what the you're talking about and
i'd be like well the cost would be 60
calories or 70 80 calories or whatever
right right it would be however many
carbs that you get with those and i just
like to break things down to a math
perspective so if you actually were just
objective about your foods
and you knew what the cost is to bring
out to intake any one of these things
that would that would take you a a very
long way instead of saying that you have
to cut out carbs for the rest of your
life or that you have to not eat cereal
for the rest of your life yeah
i get you it's kind of just like i get
no i hear that a lot you know there's no
sort of one food which is horrendous
it's sort of just like a balance if you
could um you know weigh up with how much
you've had or whatever it is i guess
that's sort of what you mean by cost
yeah yeah yeah that's exactly what i
mean it's it's just knowing exactly what
you're putting into your body rather
than reacting to the emotions or the
whims
right and a lot of times like
when people eat they're not eating
because they're hungry they're eating
because they're they're really trying to
deal with some sort of emotion that's
going through their their brains and
i'll be honest i work with somebody
i work with politicians
and freaking new york times bestsellers
they all have not all of them but
a big number probably 90 of them have an
issue
with emotional eating to some degree
so this is what i mean if you're happy
let's go eat let's go to the
lebanese place right oh yeah
you're sad let's go let's go get some
drinks and let's go eat some pizza you
know or get some ice cream or hey you
let's celebrate with like this and that
and that type of food so we have tied
food to our rewards our emotions and
then what what i have to do is literally
detail and make people objective and
then just to make people like think a
little bit deeper about the food
decisions that they're making
and with you people are self-medicating
with food getting fat getting unhealthy
and it's time for that to stop so guys
like if you want to you know change your
life follow down go okay yeah for sure i
i can't change your life
i truly believe that i truly believe
that because i've seen
yeah i don't want to talk about the
advice that i see on twitter but yeah
i've seen something okay can i go on
just go on just really quickly give us
like one bad piece of advice that you've
seen on twitter
okay the next time this piece which i
think you see
the
the worst one that i see with startup
investors that's the cryptocurrency guys
actually i've seen this with a
cryptocurrency guy so
it is the the proliferation of
doing a highly restrictive diet with
cardio
so
they're like i dropped 20 pounds
and i just did cardio and i just did a
diet
and
when we pull up their dexa scan so we do
a body fat test the dec it's called a
dexa scan and this is like the most
accurate representation of body fat bone
density and muscle so
so we do these dexa scans with them and
we see okay so let's see exactly what
happened
so i've had clients doing the exact same
thing that i said which is like losing
weight with cardio and diet
yeah they end up gaining back all the
weight
except when they redo their dexa scans
they are they are significantly less
than muscle they have lost them they
have lost about 100 points on their
metabolic rate per day
right and that's the reason why that
happens and the reason why i think
that's the death knell for anyone trying
to lose weight is because you burn
muscle and muscle is one of the things
that metabolism relies on and when i
when it comes to cardio in general
it's like taking a teaspoon and trying
to empty out a pool it's not as
effective as people think
and uh and i know you lift obviously and
personally for me like lifting is one of
the best investments that you can do if
you're above the age of like 20.
and especially if you're above the age
of 30 or 40 we start losing muscle at a
at a very rapid pace so lifting with a
proper diet that's not highly
restrictive is one of the best things
that i do for my clients
well i see that someone is already
agreeing with you andrew that's yeah
oh that's my homie right there what's up
yeah
yeah what's up andrew yeah nice to see
you
cool all right we are just over half an
hour so dan give us your final thoughts
um
yeah give us your final thoughts you
know give us something inspirational i'm
going to put you on full screen for yes
let's see if i can navigate it i can
go well
let's pre-face this by saying i'm not in
my real house right now i'm actually in
my in my wife's old bedroom when she was
like 16 18 years old so i had this live
laugh love thing behind me so this is
not this is not in my house i just want
to say that up front for anyone who
follows me i would not allow this in my
house but
my final thoughts are
just be the best that you can possibly
be i feel like the first thing that you
should do in order to reach your full
potential
is to develop and create an amazing high
performing body that is the precursor
and then afterwards you can go out and
make your money or whatever it is but
health is the number one meta habit it
is the habit that says that makes
everything easier for you
i have seen people increase their income
find their partners their life partners
i have seen people
like leave their careers and start newer
exciting ones ones that they want to be
in and in general changing your body as
a net positive for everything in your
life so i'm gonna say this please take
your health seriously and uh yes if you
need help with this then give me a shout
on twitter wherever it is shoot me a dm
dan thanks so much thank you
all right i'm gonna end the broadcast
and i'm just gonna thank everyone for
tuning in um and thank iconplus because
they powered this so they're super cool
so guys thanks for tuning in and we'll
see you thursday next week it's 12
eastern and 5 uk time cool take care bye
guys bye